This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Reporter Andrew Anderson is from the UK, but today he lives in Sofia, the capital city of Bulgaria. Andrew moved to Bulgaria because that's where his wife, Victoria, grew up. I came for a summer to try it out, and I just fell in love with it. The city was charmingly chaotic with a thriving art scene. They stayed through one summer, then a second. And after two years in Sofia, Andrew and Victoria put down roots. They decided to save money by moving out of their centrally located rental and
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。记者安德鲁·安德森来自英国，但如今他住在保加利亚的首都有索菲亚。安德鲁搬到保加利亚是因为他的妻子维多利亚在那里长大。我来这里过了一个夏天想试试看，然后就直接爱上了这里。这座城具有迷人的混乱感，艺术氛围十分浓厚。他们在那里度过了一个夏天，然后又是一个夏天。在索菲亚住了两年之后，安德鲁和维多利亚扎下了根。他们决定搬出位于市中心的出租屋，以此来省钱，并
into a little apartment owned by Victoria's family. I was kind of a bit worried about it because Vicky had told me that it's really small and really crappy and really dingy and I shouldn't have any expectations that I'm going to enjoy it and maybe we won't even move there because maybe it's going to be too much for me and I won't be able to cope with it. The apartment was in an old communist-built neighborhood called Slavia in an area called Krasnosello. Which literally translates as beautiful village. I can confirm it is not a beautiful village anymore. Now it's kind of maybe what you would have in mind
搬进了维多利亚的家人拥有一间小公寓。我其实有点担心，因为维姬曾告诉我，这房子真的很小、很破、很昏暗，叫我对它不要抱有任何能住得舒服的期望，也许我们甚至都不会搬过去，因为这对我来说可能压力太大，我根本应付不来。这套公寓位于一个名叫斯拉维亚的共产主义时期老旧社区，地处克拉斯诺谢洛。这个名字的字面意思是美丽村庄。我可以证实，这里已经不再是个美丽村庄了。现在的感觉可能有点像是你脑海中
if you were thinking of stereotypical Eastern Europe. Lots of tower blocks, lots of kiosks and things like that around. The first time Andrew went to see the apartment, he had trouble even finding it. To get there, he had to walk through a maze of overgrown paths and unmarked buildings. When he finally managed to find the right building, he still had to climb seven flights of stairs. But inside his new apartment, it was all worth it.
想象中那种刻板印象里的东欧。有许多高层公寓楼，周围还有很多报亭之类的小店。安德鲁第一次去看这套公寓时，甚至连找都找不到它。为了到那里，他必须穿过一片杂草丛生的羊肠小道和没有门牌号的建筑迷宫。当他终于找到正确的楼栋时，还得爬上七层楼梯。但一走进他的新公寓，这一切就都值得了。
When I got to the apartment and looked out the window, I was like, what a beautiful view. And once you're looking down on the neighborhood, suddenly it looks totally different because from the ground level, it's very disorganized, cluttered, messy. But once you get up here, all you can really see is trees with little apartment blocks poking up between them. So it's a totally different perspective.
当我走到公寓里并向窗外望去时，我心想，这景色真美。一旦你俯瞰整个社区，它突然间看起来就完全不同了，因为从地面水平看，这里非常杂乱、拥挤、凌乱。但一旦你来到这里，你真正能看到的就只有点缀着一座座小型公寓楼的树木。所以这是一个完全不同的视角。
Seeing from above, Sophia looks less like a city and more like a forest. And what at first looked to Andrew like a mess of winding footpaths and untamed greenery turned out to be one of Sofia's most iconic features. There's a few different things that people call them. The main term is like Mejdu block of a, which just means literally between the blocks. These green spaces between apartment buildings in Sofia are also known as interblock parks. There's hundreds of them. They're not even fully documented, so you don't really know how many there are.
从高处俯瞰，索菲亚看起来与其说是一座城市，倒不如说更像是一片森林。起初在安德鲁看来杂乱无章的蜿蜒小径和野蛮生长的绿化，后来竟成了索菲亚最具标志性的特色之一。人们对它们有几种不同的称呼。主要的术语是“Mejdu blokova”，字面意思就是“楼栋之间”。索菲亚公寓楼之间的这些绿地也被称为“楼间公园”。这里有成百上千个这样的公园。它们甚至没有被完全记录在案，所以你根本不知道到底有多少个。
The spaces aren't really parks in the western sense. They're usually not fenced in and since they all flow together, it's hard to tell where one ends and another begins. The general effect is a series of walkable rivers of green space running through the city. I could walk through old communist blocks without ever going on a road, just through these parks, because there's a footpath and then you get to a small park and then a footpath may be a bigger park, maybe just a really little one with only one swing, maybe one that's bigger and has like 10 pieces of furniture in it. You know, with everyone with their clothes like strung all the way across the thing,
这些空间并不是西方意义上的公园。它们通常没有围栏，而且由于它们全都融为一体，你很难分清一个公园从哪里结束，另一个又从哪里开始。整体呈现出来的效果就像是一条条贯穿城市的、可供人们漫步的绿色河流。我可以穿过共产主义时期的老旧小区，却完全不用走上马路，只需穿过这些公园就行，因为这里有一条小路，然后你就会来到一个小公园，接着又是一条小路，可能通向一个更大的公园，或者只是一个只有一个秋千的极小公园，也可能是一个更大、里面有大约10件休闲设施的公园。你知道的，每个人晾晒的衣服都挂满了整个架子，
sort of looks like an early Scorsese film or something like that. The part closest to Andrew's house is pretty typical of the form, if a bit more on the rustic side. It's not very big. I would guess half a football field in this case. There's a big globe climbing frame.
看起来有点像早期的马丁·斯科塞斯电影或者诸如此类的作品。离安德鲁家最近的那部分相当符合这种形式的典型特征，只是更偏向乡村风格一些。它不是很大。我猜这个大概有半个足球场那么大。这里有一个大型的地球仪攀爬架。
There's these benches. There's some ping pong tables. There's some ping pong tables. There's two ping pong tables, both of which don't have nets anymore, but they're perfect for like improvised picnic tables. So people just put their bears on them. Soon after Andrew and his family moved into the little apartment in Slavia,
这里有一些长椅。有一些乒乓球桌。有一些乒乓球桌。这里有两个乒乓球桌，这两个球桌的网都已经没了，但它们非常适合当作即兴野餐桌。所以人们经常把啤酒放在上面。安德鲁和家人搬进斯拉维亚的那间小公寓不久后，
they found themselves using the interblock park as a combination playground, event space, and social club. You end up making friends quite quickly. I lived in Manchester for eight years and I didn't know a single one of my neighbours and I know quite a lot of the people in this block and even more in the surrounding neighbourhood. Andrew is the only foreigner in his apartment block. He started going to the park every day, meeting neighbours who had grown up in Sofia and who saw the parks mostly as just another part of their daily landscape.
他们就发现自己把这个楼间公园当成了游乐场、活动空间和社交俱乐部的结合体。你最终会非常快地结交到朋友。我在曼彻斯特住了八年，却连一个邻居都不认识，但我认识这个楼里的相当多的人，甚至还认识周边社区的更多人。安德鲁是他们公寓楼里唯一的外国人。他开始每天都去公园，结识那些在索菲亚长大、把这些公园主要看作日常景观中又一部分的邻居们。
Then Andrew met someone else as fascinated by the interblocked parks as he was. My name is Ashira Morris and I am a freelance reporter based between Sofia and Florida. Andrew and Ashira are both foreigners married to Bulgarians and they shared a certain outsider's awe about the parks. I think for both of us these are spaces that like especially these people coming in from the US and the UK they just feel really special and I feel like it's one of my favorite things throughout the city in a way. Sophia's interblock parks were both unexpected and charming, especially coming from the tidy streets of
后来，安德鲁遇到了另一个和一样对楼间公园着迷的人。我叫阿希拉·莫里斯，是一名常驻索菲亚和佛罗里达的自由撰稿人。安德鲁和阿希拉都是娶了保加利亚人的外国人，他们对这些公园有着某种局外人般的惊叹。我认为对我们俩来说，这些都是非常特殊的空间，尤其是对这些从美国和英国远道而来的人来说，它们感觉真的很特别，而且我觉得这也是我在这座城市里最喜欢的事物之一。索菲亚的楼间公园既出人意料又迷人，尤其是对那些从曼彻斯特整洁的街道
Manchester or the suburban sprawl of Northern Florida. So they both took notice after a rumor started spreading through Andrew's neighborhood that his local park might be bulldozed. At the time, when I first heard about it, I was like, well, how's that possible? There's not even really much space between these blocks. Like I said, it's like two tennis courts. And also I was working under the assumption that this was public park space, so why would you build on it?
或北佛罗里达州郊区蔓延的土地过来的人来说。因此，当安德鲁的社区开始流传起当地公园可能会被推倒的谣言时，他们两个都注意到了这件事。当时，我刚听到这个消息时，我的反应是，这怎么可能呢？这些楼之间甚至没有多少空间。就像我说的，它大概就两个网球场那么大。而且我当时一直以为这是一处公共公园绿地，所以怎么可能会有人在上面搞建设呢？
Soon, a planning notice showed up. The city had given permission to a developer to put up two new apartment buildings. They would go up next to the interblock park. But the developers needed an access road into the building's parking garage. They planned to build it exactly into the building's parking garage. They planned to build it exactly where the picnic tables are now.
不久，一张规划公示贴了出来。市政府已经批准了一家开发商建造两栋新公寓楼。它们将建在楼间公园旁边。但开发商需要修建一条通往建筑地下停车场的通道。他们计划把车库入口修在现有的地方。他们计划把车库入口精确地建在现在那些野餐桌所在的位置。
I was shocked because in England it would be much harder to do that because there tends to be such rigid planning laws and I have to say I grew up living inside a national park in a place called Bayclaw that's in the Peak District National Park. So getting stuff planned, like any planning permission, they're even to like put a garden gnome in your garden can be quite tricky sometimes. Andrew Inesure started talking to experts, trying to understand how an iconic part of Sofia's urban landscape could so easily disappear. What they quickly discovered is that since the fall of Bulgarian communism in the late
我感到很震惊，因为在英国，要做到这一点要困难得多，因为那里往往有非常严格的规划法律，而且我必须说，我是在一个名为贝克洛的国家公园里长大的，那是峰区国家公园的一部分。所以要让事情获得规划批准，比如任何规划许可，哪怕只是想在花园里放一个花园小矮人，有时都会相当棘手。安德鲁和阿希拉开始与专家交谈，试图弄清楚索菲亚城市景观中如此标志性的一部分怎么会这么容易就消失。他们很快发现，自从1980年代末
1980s, Sofia has lost more than half of its green space. To understand how it happened and what the fate of the remaining parks might be, they had to go back to the origin of the capital city itself. Sophia is a really young capital, so you have a place that has been a city, but not a big city. Before it became the city of parks and apartments, Sophia was a sleepy place. It was bombed during World War II, but not as badly as other European capitals, partly
保加利亚共产主义垮台以来，索菲亚已经失去了超过一半的绿地。为了弄清楚这一切是如何发生的，以及这些剩余公园的命运将会如何，他们不得不追溯到首都本身的起源。索菲亚是一个非常年轻的首都，所以这里曾经是一座城市，但并不是一座大城市。在成为公园与公寓之城以前，索菲亚是个沉睡的地方。它在二战期间遭到轰炸，但没有其他欧洲首都那么严重，部分原因
because there just wasn't as much of a city to bomb. Bulgaria as a country overall, until communism, was very agrarian. It was not very industrial. There was not a proletariat that was working in the factories and like organizing and rising up. It was mostly farmers. The Bulgarian Communist Party came to power in 1946 when the city was home to just 400,000 people
在于当时根本没有那么多城市建筑可供轰炸。总体而言，在共产主义到来之前，保加利亚一直是个以农业为主的国家。它并不是很工业化。这里没有在工厂工作、并进行组织和起义的无产阶级。这里大多是农民。保加利亚共产党于1946年开始执政，当时这座城市仅有40万人口，
and was surrounded by farmland. The goal of Bulgaria's new communist government was to transform Sofia into a modern industrial capital. And they're looking to this farmland and they're seeing this as kind of a blank slate. As Bulgarian city planners were dreaming up a new Sofia, they knew what they were not interested in. Suburbs. Bulgarian urban planning textbooks called the kind of single family homes popping up in
四周都被农田所环绕。保加利亚新共产主义政府的目标是将索菲亚改造为一个现代化的工业首都。他们看着这些农田，将其视为一张白纸。正当保加利亚的城市规划者们构想一个新的索菲亚时，他们明确了自己不感兴趣的东西：郊区。保加利亚的城市规划教科书将当时美国涌现出的那种单户独立住宅称之为
America at the time, quote, bourgeois fascist. Instead, they opted for French modernism via the Soviet Union. Well, Gary, it was never a part of the USSR. It had its own communist dictator and its own self governance, but was also very loyal and very much in step with what the USSR was doing on a lot of different fronts. And that includes what their city planning. Here's architectural historian and critic, Aneta Vosileva. There is one architectural historian and theorist, Stanislav Formos, who is saying that if you have to describe the post-war period in three words,
“资产阶级法西斯”。相反，他们选择了通过苏联引入的法国现代主义。保加利亚从未成为苏联的一部分。它有自己的共产主义独裁者和自己的自治权，但在许多不同方面，它也非常忠诚，并且与苏联的行事步伐高度一致。这其中也包括他们的城市规划。这是建筑历史学家兼评论员安妮塔·瓦西列娃的话。有一位建筑历史学家兼理论家斯坦尼斯拉夫·福尔莫斯曾说过，如果你必须用三个词来描述战后时期，
these words would have been ruins, Stalin and Le Corbusier. Stalin ruins and Le Corbusier also happened to be in every story pitch meeting we have at 99PI. Anyway, the work of Swiss French architect, Le Corbusier inspired the USSR to move toward open geometry in its urban planning. This kind of architecture for the people, architecture for society,
这三个词将会是：废墟、斯大林和勒·柯布西耶。斯大林、废墟和勒·柯布西耶正好也是我们在99PI的每一个故事选题会上都会遇到的名字。无论如何，这位瑞士法裔建筑师勒·柯布西耶的作品启发了苏联，使其在城市规划中走向开放式几何布局。这种为人民服务的建筑、为社会的建筑、
model way of developing cities of free-standing structures within vast green areas and separate functions of housing, living, recreation, and work to rebuild the devastations of war. Le Corbusier himself, I believe, has a correspondence with some of the main city planners in Moscow. And there is an anecdote that, like all of the city planners
通过在广阔绿地中布局独立式结构，并将居住、生活、休闲和工作功能分离开来，以此重建战争毁坏之物的现代化城市发展模式。我相信，勒·柯布西耶本人曾与莫斯科的一些主要城市规划者有过书信往来。还有一个传言说，索菲亚的所有城市规划者
in Sofia had a portrait of Lookerbousier in their offices in the way that you would have the Lenin portrait. Ha ha. But alongside Lookerbousier's clean, sharp modernism, Soviet urban planners were also drawn to the British Garden City movement. The idea was that urban planners could bring the country
办公室里都挂着勒·柯布西耶的画像，就像人们挂列宁画像那样。哈哈。但除了勒·柯布西耶简洁、犀利的现代主义之外，苏联的城市规划者们也深受英国田园城市运动的吸引。其核心理念是，城市规划者可以将乡村
into the city, incorporating pockets of nature to counterbalance noise and pollution. Soviet city planners embraced the Garden City and made it their own. They talk about like having corridors of green air like move through the city. And I find it really beautiful, just the way that people talk about
引入城市，通过融入自然斑块来抵消噪音和污染。苏联的城市规划者拥抱了田园城市理念，并将其本土化。他们谈论着让绿色的空气走廊穿城而过。我发现这种说法真的很美，人们把这些环境元素描绘得仿佛具有生命一般。
these environmental elements as being kind of embodied. The dream of a fully actualized Garden City quickly spread across the Eastern Bloc. The model seemed perfectly suited to communist ideals. It was very important for them to have massive public spaces because the regime was supposed to elevate the public realm and want better way to elevate the public realm, but by having really magnificent public spaces, including parks. Sonia Hurt is a professor of landscape architecture, who first
全面实现的田园城市之梦迅速传遍了整个东欧集团。这种模式似乎与共产主义理想完美契合。拥有庞大的公共空间对他们来说非常重要，因为政权旨在提升公共领域，而有什么比拥有真正宏伟的公共空间（包括公园）更好的方式来提升公共领域呢。索尼娅·赫蒂根是一名景观建筑学教授，她童年在索菲亚长大，最早在那里体验到了景观与建筑。她说，共产主义国家绝不是唯一试图将这些理想付诸实践的地方。我认为人们很容易认为，你知道的，共产主义和资本主义在城市设计方面是不同的，但我实际上并不认为它们有何不同。
experienced landscape and architecture growing up in Sofia. She says that communist countries were far from the only places looking to put these ideals into action. I think it's easy to assume that, you know, communism and capitalism were different in terms of urban design, but I actually don't think they were. you know, communism and capitalism were different in terms of urban design, but I actually don't think they were. In terms of the design features and the design ideology of the parks, I don't think that's any different. It's simply that they were more important to the socialist regime that they were in capitalist countries,
你知道的，共产主义和资本主义在城市设计方面是不同的，但我实际上并不认为它们有何不同。就公园的设计特色和设计意识形态而言，我认为这没有什么不同。只是这些对它们所在的社会主义政权而言，比在资本主义国家中更为重要，
and also they had a greater opportunity. Capitalists and communists might have had similar tastes in city planning, but they had very different approaches to implement that planning. Starting in 1948, the Bulgarian government nationalized all private property. That meant that if you owned any land in or around Sofia, it became the property of the state. The most you might get in return was an apartment or two in a block near your former home. I think it's just very utilitarian, isn't it? Like you need somewhat, like the minimum thing you need to live is an apartment. So you get an apartment, but the farmer's living
而且他们也拥有更大的实施机会。资本主义者和共产主义者在城市规划上可能有相似的品味，但他们在落实这种规划时却有着截然不同的方法。从1948年开始，保加利亚政府将所有私有财产收归国有。这意味着如果你在索菲亚市内或周边拥有任何土地，它都会成为国家财产。你能得到的最多回报，可能也只是你前住所附近楼栋里的一两套公寓。我觉得这非常实用主义，不是吗？就像你需要某个地方一样，生活所需的最低限度就是一套公寓。所以你得到一套公寓，但农民住在
in the farmhouse, he'll get an apartment in exchange for his farmhouse, but not for the land because that's now gonna become a factory. That's now gonna become more apartment blocks. That's now gonna become a collectivized farm. Nationalization took many people away from the land their families had worked for generations, but it also cleared the way for Bulgaria to put the inspiration for a modern garden city into action. And because they don't have to go plot by plot by plot, neighbor by neighbor by neighbor,
农舍里，他会用自己的农舍换取一套公寓，但土地不行，因为那现在要变成工厂。那现在要变成更多的公寓楼。那现在要变成集体农庄。国有化夺走了许多人祖祖辈辈耕种的土地，但也为保加利亚将现代田园城市的灵感付诸实践扫清了道路。而且因为他们不必一块地接一块地、一个邻居接一个邻居地
and like get permission, they are really able to do that on a scale that is bigger and more all-encompassing than it was able to happen in a capitalist society. In the decades following the seizure of private land, Bulgarian city planners fundamentally transformed the landscape of Sofia, where there was once farmland, a series of communist planned neighborhoods fanned outwards from the city center. The earliest of these neighborhoods all tend to have a certain distinctive setup. If you think about college campuses that are very much a campus where you've got residential blocks for students that were built in the 50s and 60s, concrete, very minimalist, but
去获取许可，他们确实能够以一种比资本主义社会更大规模、更包容的方式来实现这一点。在没收私有土地后的几十年里，保加利亚的城市规划者从根本上改变了索菲亚的地貌。曾经的农田上，一系列共产主义规划的住宅区从市中心向外扇形展开。这些最早期的住宅区往往都有着某种独特的布局。如果你想想大学校园，它们非常像那种校园，里面有50年代和60年代建造的学生住宅楼，混凝土结构，非常极简主义，但
they're sat in a park in a way that'sped, and then it all drains into the center where there's the bigger buildings, like the big library, you know, the student union, things like that. It's kind of has a similar feel to that. Sophia City planners were intentional about seemingly everything. They built apartment blocks in a specific orientation that would trap heat from the sun in winter without getting too hot in the summer. The buildings were also placed so that they would block the noise from surrounding highways. And on top of the housing, the new neighborhoods had
它们以一种错落有致的方式坐落在公园里，然后所有的动线都汇聚到中心区域，那里有更大的建筑，比如大图书馆、学生会大楼之类的地方。它给人的感觉有点类似。索菲亚的城市规划者在看似一切事物上都充满着刻意的考量。他们以特定的朝向建造公寓楼，以便在冬日能捕捉阳光的热量，而夏天又不会过于炎热。这些建筑的选址也经过考量，可以阻挡周边高速公路的噪音。除了住房之外，这些新社区还拥有
all the basic amenities that you might need as a resident. There were hospitals, community centers, and schools. Everything was collectively planned. So you have a kindergarten every 200 meters and the upper grade schools every 500 meters because you know a smaller child can't walk as far. It must have been an absolute wet dream for someone like an egotist like Le Corbusier and no wonder he was like going to visit Moscow. He must have loved it. Surrounding all of this new infrastructure were Sofia's inner block parks. They were seen as an important way to put the government's communist ideals into action.
居民可能需要的所有基本便利设施。这里有医院、社区活动中心和学校。一切都是集体规划的。所以你每隔200米就会有一个幼儿园，每隔500米就会有一所高年级学校，因为你知道较小的孩子走不了那么远。对于像勒·柯布西耶这样自负的人来说，这绝对是个春梦般的极致乌托邦，难怪他会去访问莫斯科。他一定爱死这里了。环绕着所有这些新基础设施的，就是索菲亚的楼间公园。它们被视为将政府的共产主义理想付诸实践的重要途径。
The urban planners under communism were really specifically concerned about everyone having an equal share of everything. And that includes trying to think of nature as something that you can equally parse. So they wanted to make it so that everyone would have a certain amount of space in total. Most apartments built around this time were small because you weren't supposed to need that much private space. So it's not very big, you don't get a lot. But once you go outside, the green spaces between are just an extension of your apartment. It's also part of what you're living in. So anything that you maybe don't have in the house, you might have outside.
共产主义时期的城市规划者特别关心每个人是否都能均等地分享一切。这其中也包括试图将自然视为一种可以平均分配的事物。因此，他们希望做到让每个人都能获得一定总量的空间。这一时期建造的大多数公寓都很小，因为人们本不该需要那么多私人空间。所以它不是很大，你分不到多少。但一旦你走到户外，之间的绿地就成了你公寓的延伸。它也是你生活空间的一部分。所以你在屋里可能没有的东西，你在外面也许就能拥有。
Okay, I don't have anywhere to sit, and you definitely wouldn't have had a television, but there's loads of benches outside and there's people to hang out with, and there's climbing frames, there's ping pong tables. Back then with the nets still on them probably. So that's what these spaces at their best can provide. And obviously later when they were let to fall to pieces, that makes it particularly disastrous because you don't have anything else to fall back on. Like this should have been the thing that gives you the things you need to live.
好吧，我没有地方坐，而且你肯定也不会有电视，但外面有很多长椅，还有可以一起闲逛的人，有攀爬架，有乒乓球桌。当时上面大概还挂着网呢。所以这就是这些空间在最佳状态下能够提供的东西。显然，后来当它们任由破败时，这就显得尤为灾难性，因为你没有其他东西可以退而求其次。就像这本该是为你提供生活所需的事物一样。
And if you don't have those anymore, then it's a bigger problem actually losing those spaces. Almost as soon as the communist government began transforming Sofia, it was running up against the limits of its own ambition. The first communist built neighborhoods had all the amenities, but the government couldn't afford to keep them up. Under communism, there is a certain level of maintenance that comes from the city in the beginning, but there is also what's called
如果你不再拥有这些，那么失去这些空间实际上就会变成一个更大的问题。几乎在共产主义政府开始改造索菲亚的同时，它就遇到了自身雄心的极限。首批由共产主义建造的社区拥有一切便利设施，但政府却无力维护它们。在共产主义体制下，城市在初期会提供一定程度的维护，但同时也有所谓的
Leninsky-Sepotnitsi, which means Lenin Saturdays, which is this quote-unquote volunteer work where the idea was that like the people in the blocks would go and kind of do the the work of maintaining and cleaning up the spaces around them in these Mechdu Blokovay parks. I would say this is volunteering with big air quotes Time to volunteer. Yeah. Yeah But as the decades go on the maintenance just starts to fall off. By the 70s, many new neighborhoods weren't even built to completion. There were neighborhoods without schools and parks, without flowerbeds, playground equipment, or even benches.
“列宁星期六”，这意味着列宁星期六义务劳动，也就是所谓的志愿劳动，其理念是社区里的居民会去承担维护和清理这些梅杜布洛科维公园周围空间的各项工作。我得说这是带引号的志愿者服务：是时候去当志愿者了。对，没错。但随着时间的推移，维护工作开始逐渐滑坡。到了70年代，许多新社区甚至没有完全建成。有些社区没有学校和公园，没有花坛、游乐设施，甚至连长椅都没有。
Here's Sonia Hurtigan. I remember the green spaces between the housing blocks. They were not very well maintained, to be honest with you. During socialism, I think that we were simply running out of money. So the state would invest in the most ceremonial places, but the more everyday places, they were going down. Finally in late 1989, the Bulgarian Communist Party reached the end of its long decline. In November, the dictator Todor Zhivkov was forced out
这是索尼娅·蒂尔根的话。我记得住宅楼之间的绿地。说实话，它们维护得并不是很好。在社会主义时期，我认为我们只是资金耗尽了。所以国家会把资金投向那些最具有仪式感的场所，而那些更日常的地方则在走下坡路。最终在1989年末，保加利亚共产党迎来了其漫长衰落的终点。11月，独裁者托多尔·日夫科夫被迫
of office, and by December, his replacement was calling for free elections. Bulgarian communism had fallen, and as the dust cleared, the interblocked parks were the last thing on anyone's mind. The 90s was total collapse. I mean, honestly, it looked like a war had come. I mean, the least thing that municipal people would wonder about was mails. I mean, that was like a war had come. I mean, the least thing that you see value wonder about was mates. I mean, that was like, huh, you just go there. It looks like, you know, there's garbage everywhere. I mean, no one's cutting the grass. Nothing.
下台，到了12月，他的继任者开始呼吁举行自由选举。保加利亚的共产主义已经倒台，随着尘埃落定，楼间公园成了所有人脑子里最不关心的事情。90年代是全面的崩溃。我的意思是，老实说，看起来就像经历了一场战争。我是说，市政人员最不会去操心的事情就是邮箱。我是说，那就像经历了一场战争。我的意思是，你看到的最不值得操心的事情就是邮件。我的意思是，那感觉就像，哼，你直接去那儿就行。看起来就像，你知道的，到处都是垃圾。我是说，没有人割草。什么都没有。
Well, Gary's transition to democracy was peaceful, but that doesn't mean it was smooth. In the immediate aftermath of the collapse, there was a lot of optimism about democracy and capitalism. But now the new democratic government decided to undertake the absurdly complex task of identifying land that had been taken under the communist regime and giving it back to the original owners. Here's Eneta Vasileva again. It's called the Wucnikov Act. And this was part of the policies in the 90s to compensate people from this long-term socialist nationalization and state ownership.
保加利亚向民主的过渡是和平的，但这并不意味着它是一帆风顺的。在崩溃之后的初期，人们对民主和资本主义抱有极大的乐观态度。但现在，新的民主政府决定承担一项荒谬复杂的任务：甄别在共产主义政权下被没收的土地，并将其归还原主。这是安妮塔·瓦西列娃的又一段话。这被称为“乌奇科夫法”。这是90年代政策的一部分，旨在对人们长期遭受的社会主义国有化和国家所有权进行补偿。
So they returned the privately owned land, including agricultural land or metals or farm lands to their former owners or their inheritance. The situation just got more and more complicated. What started out as a very simple and on paper elegant solution, you get your land back, quickly became like an absolute nightmare banquet of disasters. Keep in mind, most of the city of Sofia was built on land that had been nationalized starting in the 40s, and almost none of it was recognizable anymore as farmland. The government's solution took that into account.
因此，他们将私有土地，包括农资土地、草地或农田，归还给了原主人或他们的继承人。情况变得越来越复杂。起初在纸面上非常简单且优雅的解决方案——你拿回你的土地——很快就变成了一场灾难的绝对噩梦盛宴。请记住，索菲亚市的大部分土地都是建立在40年代开始国有化的土地之上的，几乎没有哪一块土地还能被认出是农田。政府的解决方案考虑到了这一点。
Basically, if a building had been put on your family's land in the last 40 years, you might get some minor compensation, but you probably didn't get the land. The only way you could get land back is if that land had been left undeveloped through all of communism. So it's very, I mean, well-intentioned. It sounds from everything we've found out about it. It seems like it came from a good place and that the execution left much to be desired. In the middle of all this were the parks. Back when communist planners set up their maps they took for granted that they would never develop the parkland. So the parks were never officially listed as protected green
基本上，如果在过去的40年里，你的家族土地上已经盖了建筑，你可能会得到一些微不足道的补偿，但你大概率拿不回土地了。你能拿回土地的唯一方法，就是这块土地在整个共产主义时期一直没有被开发。所以这非常……我的意思是，出发点是好的。从我们了解到的所有情况来看。它似乎源于一个好的初衷，但执行效果却差强人意。在这这一切的中间就是公园。当年共产主义规划者绘制地图时，他们理所当然地认为自己永远不会开发这片公园用地。所以这些公园从未被官方列为受保护的绿
space. But now in this new privately owned world they weren't listed as anything. Which meant they could be given to private citizens and put up for sale. And it's only fair really if it, if you've been given land backers' compensation, why shouldn't you sell it? The fairness of it was, you get this land and you can do what you want with it. The Luchnikov Act rendered many parks essentially unusable. They were too fragmented to use and too hard to maintain. And in the end, many Bulgarians couldn't afford not to sell.
地。但现在在这个全新的私有制世界里，它们什么名分也没有了。这意味着它们可以被赠予私有公民并拿出来出售。而且说实话这也很公平，如果，如果你作为补偿拿到了土地，你为什么不能把它卖掉呢？其中的公平之处就在于，你得到了这块土地，然后你可以用它做你想做的事。《乌奇科夫法》让许多公园基本上变得无法使用。它们的碎片化程度太高，无法使用，也难以维护。到头来，许多保加利亚人根本无力不出售。
In late 1996, the Bulgarian economy collapsed and inflation hit 2,000%. So there were plenty of people looking to sell their lots. But there was really only one group of buyers wealthy enough to sell them to. Bulgaria's newly minted oligarchs. It would have been very easy for them to buy up all of that land during this period.
1996年末，保加利亚经济崩盘，通货膨胀率飙升至2000%。因此，有大量的人都在急于出售他们的地块。但实际上只有一类买家富有到足以买下它们：保加利亚新涌现的寡头。在那段时期里，他们很容易就能买下所有这些土地。
So, for example, I'm sat in my kitchen right now and looking out of my window from the seventh floor, I can see three different huge blocks that are being built. All of those are owned by an oligarch. Today's Sophia's parks are mostly private, stuck in development purgatory. Many have been turned into buildings or parking lots, but some haven't yet. And so they just sit there, ignored by the city, and falling deeper into this repair. It was totally an eye-opening experience of how things have changed. Sonya spent the first 25 years of her life in Sofia and remembers being able to walk between neighborhoods to get to her parents' apartment just using the intra-block parks.
所以，举个例子，我此刻正坐在厨房里，从七楼的窗户向外望去，我能看到正在建设的三栋巨大的公寓楼。所有这些都属于一个寡头。如今索菲亚的公园大多是私有的，陷入了开发的炼狱中。许多公园已经被改造成了建筑或停车场，但也有一些还没有。于是它们就那样静静地躺在那里，被城市所忽视，并进一步陷入失修状态。这绝对是一次大开眼界的经历，让人看到事情是如何改变的。索尼娅在索菲亚度过了她人生的前25年，她记得自己过去能够仅凭楼间公园，就在各个社区之间穿行，走到父母的公寓。
She recently returned to the city with her students and experienced the new construction firsthand. It's like a completely different space. I can't even see the mountain to know whether I'm going south. I gotta look at my phone. Sofia, actually, we had more parks per person in 1989 than any city in Europe. Now it's impossible to walk
她最近和学生们一起重返这座城市，并亲身体验了新的建设。这完全是一个不同的空间。我甚至都看不到那座山来判断自己是不是在往南走。我得看手机。实际上，与1989年相比，索菲亚人均拥有的公园数量曾比欧洲任何城市都要多。现在已经无法行走了，
because all the green spaces have been built. So when you're walking, it's a completely different sense because a lot of the former open green spaces actually have barricades because it's now a gated private compound. So yeah, I mean, the green spaces of Saudi have really diminished. I guess the good thing about it is that we had so much
因为所有的绿地都被建满建筑物了。所以当你走在其中时，感觉完全不同，因为许多曾经开阔的绿地现在都有了路障，因为它们现在成了带门禁的私人大院。所以是的，我的意思是，索菲亚的绿地确实减少了。我想好的一点是，我们曾经拥有的基数实在太大了，
that even with the diminishment it appears that we are a relatively green city, but this is because the amount to begin with was simply massive. Sonya says that in the first couple decades after the transition, a lot of people didn't seem to mind that the interblocked parks were going away. By this point, the parks were overgrown and crumbling, a reminder of what hadn't worked under communism. Because the failure was so spectacular just people gave up on the idea. So whatever the government does, it's always with suspicion. It's the government.
以至于哪怕有所减少，我们看起来仍然是一个相对绿色的城市，但这只是因为最初的绿地数量实在是太庞大了。索尼娅说，在转型后的最初几十年里，很多人似乎并不介意楼间公园正在消失。到了这个时候，公园已经杂草丛生、破败不堪，成了共产主义时期失败之作的遗迹。因为这种失败如此轰动，人们干脆放弃了这个概念。所以无论政府做什么，总是伴随着怀疑。这就是政府。
They can't possibly be good. Today, the city has that bourgeois fascist invention, the suburb. People put up fences and even mansions. In fact, Sofia residents have so thoroughly rejected the idea of public resources that many of these new mansions are actually on dirt roads. No one is funding the city to maintain that kind of shared infrastructure. So Sofia now has super fancy homes with zero infrastructure. Go figure! I mean, like, history is just fascinating.
它们怎么可能是好的呢？如今，这座城市拥有了那种资产阶级法西斯的产物——郊区。人们建起围栏，甚至盖起了豪宅。事实上，索菲亚居民对公共资源的拒绝是如此彻底，以至于这些新豪宅中的许多其实都建在土路上。没有人资助城市去维护那种共享基础设施。所以索菲亚现在拥有了超级豪华的住宅，却配零基础设施。你想想看！我的意思是，历史就是这么引人入胜。
Who could have predicted that? Still all is not lost for Sophia's interblock parks. The pendulum is swinging back and attitudes about shared space might be starting to change. I think now there is a sufficient amount of people, especially young people, who say, well, you know, I think that's absurd. You know, we still have to invest in our public spaces and the public realm. And I think the younger generation is going to be different than people who, you know, were 25 in the nineties.
谁能预测到这一点呢？不过，索菲亚的楼间公园并非全无希望。天平正在回摆，人们对共享空间的态度可能开始发生改变。我认为现在有足够多的人，尤其是年轻人，他们会说，好吧，你知道的，我认为这太荒谬了。你知道的，我们仍然必须投资于我们的公共空间和公共领域。而且我认为年轻一代将会与那些在九十年代25岁的人有所不同。
Andrew and his neighbors may be losing their park to new construction, but people in other parts of the city are also beginning to push back against development, and some have won. In other words, the fate of Sophia's remaining interblock parks is still being written. In the meantime, some Sophia residents, young and old, people who live through communism and people who didn't,
安德鲁和他的邻居们可能会因为新的建设而失去他们的公园，但城市其他地方的人们也开始抵制开发，而且有些人已经赢了。换句话说，索菲亚剩余楼间公园的命运仍在书写之中。与此同时，一些索菲亚居民，无论老少，无论是经历过共产主义的人还是没有经历过的人，
are busy doing what neither communism nor capitalism could manage to do. They are maintaining the parks. I went to one of the many parks that's like quite near the center that I had no idea existed. But I just kind of hung out there one day and this woman like a Baba like a grandma came out And she's kind of like muttering to herself a little bit and she snaps a Branch off of one of the overgrown trees and start sweeping the pavers like all the leaves and dirt and trash and everything like with her branch and then we sat and chatted for a little bit She was just like yeah, like nobody takes care of this.
都在忙着做一件无论是共产主义还是资本主义都未能成功办到的事：他们在维护公园。我去了市中心附近好几个我根本不知道其存在的公园之一。但我有一天就在那里闲逛，然后有个女人，就像巴巴（Baba，老奶奶）一样的人物走了出来。她嘴里一边嘟囔着什么，一边从一棵杂草丛生的树上折下一根树枝，然后开始清扫铺路石——把所有的树叶、泥土和垃圾都用她的树枝扫掉，接着我们坐下来聊了一会儿。她就说，是的，根本没人管这地方。
And like I come out here and I do. And this doesn't feel like the linen Saturdays. This feels something different. Yeah. I mean, I think she's old enough that she experienced them. And I think that is something that people sometimes say, of kind of like, you know, got to give it to the communists. Like they kept it clean one way or another. Next up, Kurt Colestead gives us the primer on modernism and utopia, including
然后我就会出来打理。这感觉不像是列宁星期六义务劳动。这感觉有点不一样。对。我的意思是，我觉得她年纪足够大，经历过那些时期。而且我觉得这是人们有时会说的一种说法，有点像是，“你知道的，不得不向共产党人致敬。不管怎样他们确实把这里保持得很干净。”接下来，库尔特·科尔斯特(Kurt Colestead)将为我们带来关于现代主义和乌托邦的入门介绍，其中包括
the utopian vision of our good friend, Le Corbusier. That's after the break. So, we're back with Kurt Kohlstedt, digital director and co-author of The 99% Visible City. Hey, Kurt. Hi, Roland. So, in this episode, we touched on two important concepts, Ebenezer Howard's Garden City idea and the influence of Le Corbusier. And these are such important concepts to modern urbanism.
我们好朋友勒·柯布西耶的乌托邦愿景。广告之后回来。好了，我们和数字总监、《99%隐形之城》的合著者库尔特·科尔斯特回来了。嗨，库尔特。嗨，罗曼。所以在这一期节目中，我们触及了两个重要的概念：埃比尼泽·霍华德的田园城市理念以及勒·柯布西耶的影响。这些都是现代城市主义中极其重要的概念。
We've mentioned them in different ways, the different shows over the years, but I wanted to dig a little deeper about these in particular and talk about them explicitly. Sure. Yeah, of course. So we've got Howard and Le Corbusier who are important because of these different concepts of a utopian city. But not to be left out. We also have to talk about Frank Lloyd Wright, you know, the man with the plan for everything, whether or not is in his wheelhouse. And he, of course, too, had an idea for built utopian environments around that same time. And to explain their three visions, I think we need to do like a little crash course on urban design at the turn of the 20th century.
我们在过去几年的不同节目中以不同的方式提到过它们，但我想要更深入地探讨这些特定概念，并明确地讨论它们。当然可以。是的，当然。所以我们有霍华德和勒·柯布西耶，他们之所以重要，是因为他们提出了这些不同的乌托邦城市概念。但也不能落下弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特，你知道的，那个无论是不是在他的专业领域内、对所有事情都有全盘计划的人。当然，他当时也有一个关于构建乌托邦环境的想法。为了解释他们的这三种愿景，我认为我们需要对20世纪之交的城市设计进行一次简短的速成学习。
I'm so ready for this. So let's back up a bit and set the scene. There's the Industrial Revolution, which has changed how cities work, how people work, how we make stuff, how we live. And there was so much rapid unplanned growth and industrial pollution and a growing sense that cities were dirty places and maybe we could do better. So Ebenezer Howard and Le Corbusier and Frank Lloyd Wright, they all agreed on that. You know that cities needed to be
我已经完全准备好了。那我们稍微回溯一下，设定一下背景。工业革命发生了，它改变了城市的运作方式、人们的工作方式、我们制造物品的方式以及我们的生活方式。当时有如此多迅速且缺乏规划的增长、工业污染，并且人们越来越感觉到城市是个肮脏的地方，或许我们本可以做得更好。所以埃比尼泽·霍华德、勒·柯布西耶和弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特，他们在这点上都达成了一致。你知道的，城市需要变得
safer, healthier, more equitable. And they also shared a belief that incrementally fixing those kinds of current conditions in cities wasn't gonna cut it. They needed to make big changes and in some cases that meant starting from scratch. So their view was that cities were so dirty, so dangerous, they needed to be radically rethought. So what was their proposal to fix that? Well, let's start with Ebenezer Howard because he's the oldest of the lot and he called his
更安全、更健康、更公平。他们还共同坚信，仅仅通过小修小补来改善城市中那种现状是远远不够的。他们需要做出重大改变，在某些情况下，这意味着一切从头开始。所以他们的观点是，城市是如此肮脏、如此危险，以至于需要进行彻底的重新构想。那么他们解决这个问题的提议是什么呢？好吧，让我们从埃比尼泽·霍华德开始，因为他是这些人中最年长的，他将他的
utopian idea the Garden City, which was mentioned in the show. And we talked about urban greenery in that context, but there's more to it than that. Howard's thinking was cities are just too big to be healthy and happy. But towns are too small for, you know, the new industrialized world. So we had this hybrid solution, which was to start with a circular civic center, basically like a round shaped downtown. And the circle would be surrounded by a series of other circles sort of strung together like a necklace of pearls around the outside. But of course also linked to that middle circle.
乌托邦构想称为“田园城市”，节目中也提到过这一点。我们在那个语境下讨论了城市绿化，但其中还有更多内容。霍华德的想法是，城市太大了，无法保持健康和快乐。但城镇对于（你知道的）这个新的工业化世界来说又太小了。所以我们有了这个混合解决方案，那就是从一个环形的公民中心开始，基本上就像是一个圆形的市中心。这个圆将被一系列其他圆所环绕，它们就像珍珠项链一样串联在外面。但当然，它们也与中间的那个圆相连。
And so of course all of this would be interconnected but also somewhat autonomous. Yeah. So I'm picturing this like spokes on a wheel like connecting the outer circles to the innermost one. Is that right? Yeah, yeah, that's exactly it. And so it was a spatial idea, right? But it was also a political one.
所以当然，所有这一切都是相互连接的，但在某种程度上也是相对自治的。对。所以我在脑海中想象这就像车轮上的辐条一样，将外圈连接到最内圈。是这样吗？对，对，完全是这样。所以这是一个空间概念，对吧？但它也是一个政治概念。
He thought that at smaller scales, we could break things up into pieces and power could be more decentralized and people would then work together, they'd share ownership and collectively build their own slice or circle of paradise. Well, I can certainly see how that dovetailed with the Bulgarian communists and what they were thinking at the time. Oh, yeah, right. I mean, it very much aligns politically. And the name embodies this very physical idea of garden cities with rings of greener
他认为，在较小的尺度上，我们可以把事情化整为零，权力可以更加去中心化，这样人们就会共同合作，他们会分享所有权，并共同建立他们自己的那份乐园或天堂之环。好吧，我当然能看出这与保加利亚共产党人及他们当时的思想是如何契合的了。哦，是的，确实如此。我的意思是，它在政治上高度一致。这个名字本身就体现了田园城市的这种非常具象的理念，周围环绕着不同节点的绿化
near on different nodes. That was also aesthetically and sort of culturally appealing. And then there would be these rings of agriculture around the perimeter that would naturally sort of, you know, enclose the whole thing, limit expansion and keep everything to this kind of ideal utopian middle size, at least in theory. Yeah. In theory. Utopias are always in theory.
圆环。这在审美和文化上也很有吸引力。然后在周边还会有这些农业环带，它们会很自然地（你知道的）包围整个系统，限制城市扩张，并把一切维持在这种理想的乌托邦中等规模，至少在理论上是这样的。对。在理论上。乌托邦永远都只存在于理论中。
Okay. Yeah, exactly. So that's the utopia. Number one, the decentralized collectivist garden city. And then along comes Frank Lloyd Wright Now he's a famous rugged individualist and he has a rather different idea which he calls broadacre city and In his utopian system everybody would get their own small plot of land
好吧。对，没错。这就是那个乌托邦。第一种，去中心化的集体主义田园城市。接着登场的是弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特。现在，他是一位著名的粗犷个人主义者，他有着相当不同的想法，他称之为“广亩城市”，在他的乌托邦系统中，每个人都能分到自己的一小块土地
Which would be like a little farm a a little space, a little nature, a little house. So Wright thought that, you know, these big changes in transit and telecommunications were going to connect us into the future in new ways. And that with those big innovations, dense cities would just kind of become obsolete. So on the one hand, he's a bit of a futurist, but he's also a bit of a traditionalist because he's really obsessed with the family, which he sees as being threatened by the modern world and He thought that they would find harmony in these you know individual sort of traditional American homes. Yeah. Yeah I mean this sounds pretty much like Suburbia though. Yeah. Yeah, it's a very it's just like a dressed up kind of nicer looking suburbia on steroids because
就像是一个小农场、一点空间、一点自然、一栋小房子。所以赖特认为，交通和电信方面的这些巨变将以崭新的方式把我们联结到未来。随着这些伟大的创新，密集的城市将变得过时。所以一方面，他有点像个未来主义者，但他也是个传统主义者，因为他极度痴迷于家庭，他认为家庭正受到现代社会的威胁，而他认为人们会在这些独特的、某种程度上传统的美国住宅中找到和谐。是的，没错，这听起来太像郊区了。是的，这就像是打了兴奋剂、经过粉饰且更好看的郊区，因为
As much as people are spaced out in suburbia on steroids because as much as people are spaced out in suburbia, you look at his drawings for this and people are spaced out even more. And so even though he worked with a lot of circles too, it was pretty much the opposite of the guarded city politically because, you know, that was all about collectivism, right? This was always about individualism. Okay, so that's Howard and Wright. So let's talk about Le Corbusier, the architects, architect. Yes, indeed.
就像郊区里的人们之间隔得很远一样——这是打了兴奋剂的郊区，因为郊区里的人们本来就住得很分散，如果你看他为此画的设计图，人们之间的距离甚至还要远得多。尽管他也使用了许多圆圈，但在政治上，这几乎与有防御工事的城市完全相反，因为那种城市追求的是集体主义，对吧？而这里追求的始终是个体主义。好吧，这就是霍华德和赖特。现在我们来谈谈勒·柯布西耶，建筑师中的建筑师。是的，确实如此。
So we've got the Garden City, Co-operative Nature, and Broadacre City, which is all about the individual. And then we have Corbuseradient City, which is all about centralized power. So in some ways, it was like the opposite of rights vision of distributed living. And in some ways it was like the opposite of Howard's idea of like collectivist control. In Corbou's Radiant City illustrations,
所以我们有了花园城市、合作自然和广亩城市，而广亩城市完全关乎个人。接着是柯布西耶的灿烂城市，它完全关乎集中权力。所以在某种程度上，这就像是赖特分布式生活愿景的对立面。在某种程度上，它又像霍华德集体主义控制理念的对立面。在柯布西耶灿烂城市的插图中，
individual houses are just not there. People just live in these towering apartment blocks. And, you know, so while in the Garden City you have these small nodes that are semi-autonomous, the radiant city is like this huge urban machine in which everything is centralized and planned out. And he compared it to like a body and like the various functions of a body, like every piece is part of the whole, but it all does its own thing. But it's all just extremely regimented. And in between these tall structures, he too had green open space and tons of transit options. So in Sofia, it sounds like they were borrowing a bit from Colomé in the garden city and a bit
压根找不到独立的房屋。人们只是住在这些高耸的公寓大楼里。所以，当花园城市里有着半自主的小型节点时，灿烂城市就像是一个巨大的城市机器，其中一切都是集中的、规划好的。他把它比作一个身体以及身体的各种机能，就像每个部分都是整体的一部分，但各司其职。只是这一切都极其军事化。在这些高大的建筑之间，他同样设计了绿色的开阔空间和大量的交通选择。所以在索菲亚，听起来他们有点借鉴了柯布西耶的花园城市，又有点
from Colomé C, which is the radiant city. We've got this collectivist approach and egalitarian ideals of Howard's Garden City, but the central planning of the radiant city, plus Corbou's towers with large stretches of green space in between. But kind of nothing from the Broadacre City, right? Yeah, no, really. I mean, it was like the antithesis of what they were going for, right? They were scared of suburban development. They wanted something that was at least somewhat urban. Yeah. And this was hinted at the piece, right? Like, this is what they were talking about, how they didn't want to that American model to be their model. Right. But the thing is, you know, for all of these
借鉴了灿烂城市。我们既有霍华德花园城市的集体主义方法和平均主义理想，又有灿烂城市的中央集权规划，再加上柯布西耶的塔楼以及其间大片的绿地。但基本上没有借鉴广亩城市的东西，对吧？是的，确实没有。我的意思是，这简直就是他们追求目标的对立面，对吧？他们害怕郊区的开发。他们想要某种至少带点城市感的东西。是的。而文章中也暗示了这一点，对吧？就像他们在讨论的那样，他们不希望把美国模式作为他们的模式。对的。但问题是，你知道，尽管有所有这些
differences and all these ways in which they're polar opposites, they actually have a bunch of stuff in common too. Like they all were really into using geometry as part of the solution to, like, really make it feel rational and mathematical. And a lot of optimism too, right? They all had to believe that cities could be healthier and greener, and in listening to the episode, that's what really struck me about like the experience in Sophia, because in whatever form, we all need and want access to light and greenery. They were smart enough to know that these
分歧和南辕北辙的地方，他们其实也有很多共同点。比如他们都非常热衷于将几何图形作为解决方案的一部分，好让它感觉理性且富有数学美感。而且还充满乐观主义，对吧？他们都必须坚信城市可以变得更健康、更环保。在听这期节目时，索菲亚的经历最让我震撼的正是这一点，因为无论以何种形式，我们都需要并且渴望阳光与绿意。他们足够聪明，知道这些
were fundamental truths, and no matter what you built in between, these things were required. Yeah, Yeah. The building blocks of a good city. Thank you so much, Kurt. I appreciate it. Thanks, Robyn. 99% Invisible was reported this week by Andrew Anderson and Ashera Morris, edited by Kelly Prime with help from Chris Berube, additional production from Jacob Moultonato-Madina and Kurt Colsted. Special thanks to Asperu Delchev,
是基本真理，无论你在中间建造了什么，这些东西都是必不可少的。没错，没错。好城市的基石。非常感谢你，柯特。我很感激。谢谢你，鲁本。本周的《99%无形》由安德鲁·安德森和阿舍拉·莫里斯报道，凯利·普莱姆编辑，克里斯·贝鲁比提供协助，雅各布·莫尔纳托-马迪纳和柯特·科尔斯特德进行额外的制作。特别感谢阿斯佩鲁·德尔切夫、
Colleen Yanakiev, Mariah Taylor, and the experts from Ekiputna, Sofia. Sound mix by Zeke Ben Ahmad Fari, music by Swan Real, fact checking by Graham Hesha, our executive producer is Kathy too, Delaney Hong is our senior editor. The rest of the team include Sarah Bake, Emmett Fitzgerald, Gabriella Gladney, Martine Gonzalez, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Lay, Jason De Leon, LaShamadon,
科琳·亚纳基耶夫、玛丽亚·泰勒以及来自索菲亚 Ekiputna 的专家们。声音混音由齐克·本·艾哈迈德·法里负责，音乐由天鹅之实制作，事实核查由格雷姆·赫沙完成，我们的执行制片人是凯茜·涂，德兰尼·洪是我们的资深编辑。团队的其他成员包括萨拉·贝克、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、加布里埃拉·格拉德尼、马丁·冈萨雷斯、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、薇薇安·莱、杰森·德·莱昂、拉沙马顿、
Joe Rosenberg, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% Visible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. 99% Visible is part of the Stitcher and SiriusXM podcast family now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. And beautiful. Uptown, Oakland, California. If you haven't already, pick up a copy of The Power Broker by Robert Carroll and join our Power Broker Book Club. New episodes of the 99% of visible breakdown of of the power broker hosted by me and Elliot Kalin will drop monthly right here in this feed. It's a real party over there. So I hope you can join it. We're having so much fun. You can find us on all the usual social media sites. And we
乔·罗森伯格，还有我，罗曼·马尔斯。《99%无形》的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯创作。《99%无形》现在是 Stitcher 和 SiriusXM 播客家族的一部分，总部位于潘多拉大楼向北六个街区的地方。这里美丽迷人。加利福尼亚州奥克兰市上城。如果你还没看过，快去买一本罗伯特·卡罗的《权力经纪人》，并加入我们的权力经纪人读书俱乐部吧。由我和埃利奥特·卡林主持的《权力经纪人》拆解节目的新单集将每月准时在这个订阅源发布。那边可真是一个热闹的派对。所以我希望你能加入我们。我们玩得可开心了。你可以在所有常见的社交媒体网站上找到我们，我们
just started a new 99 PI discord server. Come join me and the rest of the team to talk about the power broker and architecture books, movies, any kind of random stuff, story ideas you might have. It's a good time. You can find a link to that as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
刚刚建立了一个新的 99 PI Discord 服务器。快来加入我和其他团队成员，一起讨论《权力经纪人》、建筑书籍、电影、各种随机话题，或者你可能有的故事创意吧。这是一个好时光。你可以在 99PI.org 上找到该链接以及 99PI 的每一期往期节目。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可留下评论。